you can't get any more out of touch than
this the biting administration literally
laughing at americans struggling with
inflation check out this ridiculous
answer from joe biden's energy secretary
watch
in sturgis michigan
it is
2.89 cents a gallon i guess that's
better than in california what is the
grand home plan to increase oil
production in america
oh my god
that is hilarious wood that i had the
magic wand on this oil is a global
market it is controlled by a cartel that
cartel is called opec and they made a
decision yesterday that they were not
going to increase beyond what they were
already planning wow i didn't think it
can get worse than kamala harris
giggling when she's uncomfortable pete
but you know who's not laughing the
electorate i mean you got virginia new
jersey it's happening in smaller
districts where
progressives are losing control
americans are really fed up on this
issue yeah that reminds me of obama
talking about the magic wand as well
which didn't come back to him either i
mean
what what joe biden did when the
elections right before the elections in
virginia uh and new jersey was
completely emblematic of the disconnect
you're talking about lawrence he's over
in glasgow he's over in italy talking
about climate change and emissions while
people on the campaign trail are talking
about curriculum in schools inflation
our border a retreat in afghanistan all
the things that that pertain to their
lives and our nation's honor their talk
their protesting at joe manchin saved my
life i'm about to die because of climate
change and they're listening to those
things in this particular case they
listen so much that they undercut our
own energy independence at home and then
laugh and say well it's a cartel in opec
and we need to beg them for more oil
what do you want me to do what do you
want me to do not cancel our pipelines
not crush our ability to create domestic
opportunities here at home so the only
one laughing is us at them with the
sheer incompetence they've had so far in
handling this yeah but degan there's a
message coming out of the white house
and the democratic party at large is
that nothing is happening they're doing
well it's not their fault
it's a demand issue
every single issue
they are excelling and the american
people are rejecting them so when are
they going to get a clue
they won't i will say
at this table what i said watching this
screaming it out loud in my office by
myself
listening to the energy secretary is it
too much to ask that the secretary of
energy actually understands how the
energy sector works and how energy
production works is it too much to ask
for her to give at least a small cold
dam
about the suffering that all americans
are facing as they try to say oh do i
eat spaghetti for dinner or do i buy a
steak because i've got to fill up my car
tomorrow morning
let me just point this what she said was
totally
disingenuous the united states broke
opec broke the cartel we became a net
exporter of oil and oil products under
president trump we became the world's
swing producer that means that we
control the global price of oil because
we had so much spare production capacity
so she's talking about opec containers
the price it's a global commodity we
control the price until you took a
chainsaw you and your liberal nuts to
one of our most valuable industries and
took a chainsaw to our global security
you handed power to nations that hate us
that's and she can laugh about that too
jessica should the president summons her
to the oval he he campaign on president
empathy this doesn't seem very
empathetic
it's not a good idea to laugh at voters
and you're laughing at voters also of
your own party it's 80 of america is
upset about inflation right now that's
wide swaths majorities of everyone
independence the most
alongside republicans but democrats are
feeling the heat too along with these
prices and to return to the empathy
point yes joe biden
won this election
by being empathetic and saying i can get
us through this global health pandemic
i'm the right guy to do that and you saw
that coming up as a problem specifically
in the virginia election you can't
dismiss the way people feel you have to
keep talking to them this was the same
thing that they found over and over with
getting people to take the vaccine don't
tell them that they're an idiot because
they don't want to take it explain the
benefits of it explain the science of it
how much better your life will be that
you're going to be protecting those that
you know and love
jen granholm
was a very good governor a great person
i'm
it was a mistake though and so it's
going to be run in the midterms that's
just i see that and i'd say there's a
midterm that was really nasty and jesse
here's the problem we could have
discussed energy policy and all of this
during the campaign but it was an
emotional campaign we didn't didn't get
to talk about the facts and where each
candidate in the media covered for them
and so she's laughing but they ran on
this they ran on this so they had no
empathy on this issue joe said america's
back prove it you just got on your knees
and begged opec to increase production
and they just gave joe the middle finger
we just gave joe the middle finger
opec
we're supposed to be back we're just
gonna get talked to like by shakes in
the desert like that no remember trump
used to jawbone the saudis guys you know
how much we're paying to protect your
kingdom
you want this uh weapons package to go
through do you want us to stay tough on
the muellers in iran we'll pump that oil
king and they pump that oil and that's
why prices were slow also as you so well
said we had domestic production up not
only in oil but in natural gas you have
low gas prices that's downward pressure
on world oil prices he just went and
fell asleep at glasgow at a climate
conference where all his buddies said
we're going to destroy petroleum in 30
years what do you think the shakes said
then oh really guys we're just going to
slow things down a little bit over here
so you can feel the pain you know maybe
feel some pain without some oil see what
that feels like they're just laughing
all the way to the bank wait till winter
comes lawrence you know how expensive
home heating prices are going to be
you're going to have high home heating
prices high inflation high gas prices
that hasn't happened since the 70s
remember what carter said in the 70s if
you guys are cold in your house he said
put a sweater on jessica's going to have
to knit me a sweater that's what i'll do
for my maternity you're going to have to
i'll make you so many outfits okay so
you don't have to pay more
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else